bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
dans le kiosque votre magazine culturel
regardons ensemble le sommaire de cette
émission le théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines présentait ce
mercredi à la presse sa nouvelle saison
découverte en avant-première des grands
événements avec son directeur jacques
borno lundi se tenait à paris la finale
du trophée d'impro culture et diversité
parmi les cinq villes participantes les
collégiens de trappes défendez leur
ville pour la quatrième année une finale
marquée par la présence inattendue du
président de la république l'espace de
covile deux voisins va vibrer samedi 31
mètres la quatrième édition de métal ce
faire un concert en plein air dédié au
métal alternatif nicolas gervais nous
présente le programme de la soirée ce
matin le théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines présenté à la
presse en avant première la
programmation de sa nouvelle saison je
vous propose de découvrir quelques-uns
des 50 spectacles qui seront présentés
il ya quelques artistes qui reviennent
régulièrement dont on aime bien suivre
le parcours d'années après année - on
peut citer sonia wieder atherton qui
ouvre là qui ouvre la saison non ce sera
peut-être la quatrième ou cinquième
apparition de ces dernières années dans
une création un hommage à nina simone
qui va attend beaucoup parce que les va
rendre hommage à la musicienne
incroyable qui était mis la simone on a
effectivement decouflé qui revient avec
une forme cabaret qui raconte la
création d'une comédie musicale on
savait quelque chose de
je pense de très très très drôle et en
même temps de très très beaux
plastiquement et musicalement aussi
comme comme sait le faire dégonfler
on a des formes nouvelles aussi
je parle par enchaînement mais avec le
cabaret puisqu'on appareils cabaret
disent très pompeux par le couple et on
parle aussi une proposition de mark
tompkins ce qui est ouvertement lié au
cabaret on peut parler de wenzhou pose
donc on a une forme artistique est très
peu présent presque jamais présent dans
la programmation qui va être présenté
cette fois on a de grandes figures de la
danse internationale qui vont venir à
saint quentin en yvelines et notamment
alonzo king pour la première fois à 50
on y dîne alonzo king c'est un
chorégraphe c'est un maître de ballet
absolument
c'est une référence tous les grands
chorégraphes rencontre alonzo king c'est
quelqu'un qui a une capacité on va dire
à inventer une chorégraphie nouvel
attrait très fort très belle relation si
avec la musique que ce soit déjà ce soit
gospel qu'associé la musique classique
une dimension spirituelle et qui fait
une danse qu'on peut qualifier de néo
classique dans la forme avec des
danseurs prodigieux et il s'est aussi
allié une très très grande émotion on ne
sort pas on va dire indemme bon sens du
terme de ses spectacles on a aussi les
chorégraphies de forsythe william
forsythe qui vont être donnés par le
ballet un des plus prestigieux ballet en
france le ballet de l'opéra de lyon qui
a depuis pas mal d'années
porter on va dire le répertoire de
william forsythe et là ça va s'inscrire
dans le cadre d'un hommage à force ait
rendu par le festival d'automne donc on
a la chance d'être un des points de
présentation de ce grand corps écran une
des caractéristiques dont on n'a
peut-être pas assez parlé c'est le fait
qu' il y aura pas mal de spectacles
disons qu'il ya beaucoup de comédies
beaucoup d'humour beaucoup d'humour dans
tous les registres
alors vous pourrez retrouver
l'intégralité de cet entretien mené par
nicolas gervais le 25 juin dans le
kiosque lundi se tenait à paris la
finale du trophée
d'improvisation culture et diversité un
championnat national
intercollèges d'improvisation donc
théâtrale et parmi les cinq villes
participantes les collégiens de trappes
des fondé pour la quatrième année leur
ville une finale marquée par la présence
inattendue du président de la république
venu soutenir le théâtre d'improvisation
comme discipline à part entière de l'est
depuis l'éducation culturelle et
artistique et des images des lots dit
'mon
avec de lacharrière parce que c'est lui
qui a lancé cette idée vie
j'étais un rapport aussi avec jamais le
mus par ce qu'il vient de faire
rae qui m'avait convaincu de venir
assister à un match d'improvisation que
la femme
l'avait promis à trappes en février
dernier et il l'a fait françois hollande
était lundi au théâtre le comédia à
paris pour remettre le trophée d'impro
culture et diversité un championnat
national intercollèges d'improvisation
théâtrale cinq villes participer au
tournoi bordeaux lille rochechouart
trappe et cette année paris entrée dans
la compétition venus en invité surprise
ce sont des mains du président de la
république que les jeunes gagnants
bordelais se sont vu remettre le trophée
d'impro 2014
et il y a quatre ans par la fondation
culture et diversité et jamel debbouze
parrain de l'événement qui a lui-même
fait ses premiers pas de comédien grâce
au théâtre d'impro tout a changé la
culture à muette où tous les gamins les
gamins sont plus du tout les mêmes ils
ont une autre énergie ils ont d'autres
problématiques ils ont d'autres sujets
de conversation et j'en doute rapport à
tous donc sur la patinoire on l'entend
on voit bien il exorcise tout donc si
oui juste d'entendre un peu et je vous
assure que c'est impressionnant on en a
si l'étude sociologique marrante ahmad
j'en prends
depuis avoir honte de moi ne plus avoir
peur des autres de plus être dans le
jugement constamment de ce que j'étais
ou de ce qu'on pouvait penser
ça va apporter un triste de confiance
certains peut-être excessives parfois
mais mais c'est vrai que ça m'a donné ça
m'a donné du courage ça m'a donné de la
force il d'être applaudi par des gens je
vous jure que ça ça me remonte le moral
et peu importe ce qui se passe chez vous
s'aguerrisse et salvateur session
salvateur c'est aussi ce que pense la
nouvelle génération pour qui le théâtre
d'improvisation est un moyen de sortir
de l'échec scolaire je sais que c'est
l'impro existerait pas dans mon collège
j'avais sans doute décroché l'école
franchement ça fait plaisir tout savoir
que dans quelques années ce sera tous
les jeunes de trappes qui feront sa
larmes aux yeux quand on s'est dit que
ça l'horizon de nous sa salle est
impressionnant c'est le meilleur moyen
de représenter les jeunes france avec la
collaboration de la mythique compagnie
d'improvisation théâtrale déclic théâtre
reconnu à trappes pour ses actions en
faveur de l'éducation artistique et
culturelle auprès des collégiens le
trophée d'impro culture et diversité a
pour objectif d'étendre au niveau
national pratique artistique ce qui est
très important justement c'est ça c'est
que ça devienne une pratique culturelle
et artistique et
et pas seulement un truc qu'on fait pour
rigoler ça fait très longtemps qu'il
existe des bac pro ça fait très
longtemps qu'on travaille en tant que
les assauts théâtrale avec les enfants
avec les ados et avec les adultes en
professionnel en amateur et c'est bien
que enfin le monde de la culture
commence à se dire que c'est vraiment de
l'art c'est vraiment de la culture c'est
vraiment des productions artistiques
intéressante parce qu'elles sont
éphémères et que c'est ça qui est
chouette et du coup la présence du
président de la république aujourd'hui
c'était aussi une reconnaissance
institutionnelle du match d'impro dans
le cas de l'île de l'éducation
artistique et culturelle on est en train
de travailler avec le ministère de la
culture le ministère de l'éducation
nationale pour cette reconnaissance donc
c'est quand même un grand pas pour le
match d'impro cette année le président
de la république deux ministres présents
ce lundi celui de l'éducation et de la
culture en effet un grand pas pour
l'improvisation théâtrale qui forte de
cette reconnaissance institutionnelle
invite de nouvelles villes à rejoindre
le trophée d'impro
alors au cours de sa visite françois
hollande annoncé qu'il souhaitait que
l'option théâtre puisse être encouragés
dès le collège aurélie filippetti
ministre de la culture approuvent cette
proposition en écoute
dès le collège pour que vous puissiez
aller danser
je
suis heureuse qu'elle présente la
république soit attaché à la défense de
du théâtre et du théâtre au collège
parce que c'est comme ça qu'on peut
découvrir qu'on peut faire aimer le
théâtre et qu'on peut emmener les jeunes
sur le chemin de la culture
de l'éducation nationale benoît hamon
également présent ce lundi lors de la
finale du trophée impro culture et
diversité nous a confié penser à inclure
le théâtre d'impro comme une des
disciplines pouvant être proposées dans
le cadre des rythmes scolaires on écoute
également
je trouve ça remarquable d'imagination
de drôlerie qui en plus son coût à ma
japon on improvise mais il ya des règles
ça prend tout ça à la fois
ce qui m'amène à penser que eux dans le
cadre de la fameuse réforme des rythmes
scolaires qui permet
ok on encourage les villes à proposer
des activités au delà du temps d'école
voilà une chose qui va peut-être falloir
qu'on développe et qu'on travaille avec
la réforme d'eric on a une belle
occasion
encore être dupliqué
les matchs d'impro mais progressivement
il s'agit pas que en apport de quoi il
faut y aller doucement que je pense à
une belle idée voilà en marge du trophée
alain degois dit papy le fondateur de la
compagnie déclic théâtre qui pendant
vingt ans a oeuvré à défendre le théâtre
d'impro s'est vu remettre la médaille de
chevalier des arts et des lettres
entouré des ministres de la culture et
de l'éducation
une reconnaissance de la pratique de
l'improvisation théâtrale comme un art à
part entière
alors d'abord je voudrais
faire part de ma déception
enfin pas de la mienne en fait celle de
mon fils augustin qui quand il a su que
j'étais chevalier aller il m'a dit les
papilles
papa est ce que tu vas avoir une épée
je suis dit manon ses voyelles et p
alors il a dit alors c'est nul
ouais
chevalier des arts et des lettres
cirque c'est même ça ne m'est fleuret
même pas à l'esprit au fur et à mesure
d'avoir conscience qu'il fallait me
battre pour faire exister cette
discipline oui ça je l ai eu très tôt et
d'ailleurs la ceiba c'est une vraie
consécration d'avoir les deux ministres
de tutelle de
de l'éducation nationale et de la
culture qui me qui seront l'avenir aussi
de sept de ces disciplines qui fait
partie des gens qui font bouger les
lignes de la culture qui montre que
l'accusé n'est pas réservé à une petite
caste la culture c'est pour tous et pour
tous les français et aussi pour les
français dans les quartiers difficiles
et que on a besoin d'avoir de faire
vivre toute cette créativité tous ses
talents il l'a fait pendant toute sa vie
avec déclic théâtre
avec les matchs d'improvisation
théâtrale avec le théâtre
d'improvisation qui est un art à part
entière et j'étais très heureuse de
pouvoir le décor est aujourd'hui les
arts et lettres
les talons de demain seront peut-être
celle du 24 mai sur la scène du pôle
musical blaise pascal à magny les
hameaux la 3e édition du concert la voie
en scène se prépare nous avons suivi les
répétitions des images de clerck en bien
l'association la voix en scène organisme
agréé de formation en coaching vocal et
scénique organise pour la troisième
année consécutive un concert de
découverte de talents samedi 24 mai les
élèves daudré bruins seront sur scène
mais pour l'heure place aux répétitions
cette année on a vraiment choisi une
formule acoustique à la différence des
deux éditions précédentes où on était
sur un live complet et là du coup
guitare voix piano voix mais c'est ce
qui en fait fait
cette harmonie eux ça leur permet de
travailler sur un projet déjà d'avoir à
un objectif
et puis 2 2 par exemple pour les
amateurs ils se préparent ils à ses
musiciens il répète il doit travailler
la technique vocale et va travailler la
scène il doit la voilà il ya tout un
processus autour de ça leur donnait
accès à ça aussi
marylise travaille le chant avec audrey
depuis six ans le concert est pour elle
un moment de défi face à ces émotions
qu'il faudra à la fois transmettre et
maîtrisée malgré tout c'est l'occasion
déjà d'avoir un retour sur soi même
parce qu'on voit ce qu'on est capable de
transmettre après un bon il ya des
photos il ya des vidéos bien évidemment
donc ça nous permet aussi de travailler
différemment peut-être ensuite pour le
prochain concert et puis c'est surtout
un grand moment de partage puisqu'on est
pour beaucoup en cours individuels donc
là on se retrouve tous ensemble qu'il
faut apprendre à partager beaucoup de
choses faut apprendre la patience faut
prendre du scénic chose qu'on fait pas
forcément en cours donc ça ça rajoute
plein d'éléments plein de bonnes choses
à ce que l'on fait déjà chez nous les
bases qu'on chante énormément donc j'ai
toujours chanté
avec plus ou moins de gens autour de moi
et donc là je me suis dit qu'il fallait
peut-être quand même travailler
certaines choses surtout la transmission
de l'émotion c'est pas toujours facile
et j'attendais donnerait justement
qu'elle m'aide à respirer et à map aisée
quand je chante que ma voix ne
trahissent pas cette émotion et ça moi
c'est mon challenge à chaque fois michel
est auteur compositeur et interprète
après quatre années de cours de chant
ses attentes portent aujourd'hui avec
audrey sur le coaching scénique l'avoir
en scène représente une formidable
expérience d'interprétation sur celles
de ses propres compositions dans mes
chansons j'essaie de donner un maximum
de poids aux homos et c'est important
pour moi d'être à fond dans
l'interprétation scénique petit à petit
on apprend à se déplacer un peu mieux on
apprend à regarder aussi le public à se
fixer un peu sur
fixer son regard et puis on apprend à
développer aussi à des attitudes pour
pourrait être un peu plus dans ses
textes ils seront accompagnés samedi 24
mai au pôle musical baisse pascal à
magny les hameaux par des musiciens
professionnels pour deux concerts live
18h à 21h
samedi 31 mai c'est l'espace 2 co villes
de voisins-le-bretonneux qui va vibrer
au son du métal pour la quatrième
édition de métal ce faire un concert en
plein air dédié locaux métal alternatif
nicolas gervais nous présente le
programme de l'asfa y
le quatrième opus de metal sphère conçu
permettent à ce festival dédié au métal
c'est le 31 mai
dit m ouais bah rentrée la nouvelle
salle la halle elle qu'elle vend du
bombardier
c'était
cash qui devrait clôturer center
clac fait qu'ils breach
son magnifique
c'est la quatrième édition du mouves
faire ça se passe le 31 mai prochain à
l'espace culturel decauville de
voisins-le-bretonneux metallica c'est un
événement de 10 au métal alternatif donc
ces douze groupes pour en pour deux
scènes en extérieur de 15h à 1h du matin
l'année dernière on était la première
édition en plein air donc on avait à la
fois une scène en extérieur et une scène
à l'intérieur cette année on passe le
cap totalement ces deux scènes
extérieures
pour profiter totalement du beau temps
qui va arriver concessions
son
des groupes assez assez pointilleux
c'est étrange un exemple à qui me vient
en tête c'est ca cl c'est un groupe de
technique métal donc en fait leur
principe c'est de mélanger le métal à de
la musique
origine arabo berbère
m
highbury
les yeux
notre grosse tête d'affiché très pallium
c'est un groupe ii
de death metal death metal un peu
moderne
il
mais
mendoze construction mon retour je
les black metal et du death metal donc
notamment aux barques rhône et regarde
les hommes tomber l'idée du mitage cela
c'est aussi de construire de construire
une programmation avec des groupes
locaux qui sont assez fédérateur donc
notamment back in bing com qu'on connaît
bien mais ta sauce parce qu'ils sont pas
pour rien dans la création de metas
faire et séné 2 2 à la base et encore
aujourd'hui êtes beaucoup dans la
création de l'événement on aura aussi un
un groupe de rambouillet qui est qui et
mecha aura un groupe à à découvrir qui
va qui va vite monté
petite nouveauté de l'année c'est que
l'a compris mais c'est de les chercher
des op
à l'étranger donc qu'ils sont eux qui
peuvent êtres tower et
au kingston wikimini scène vient de
lituanie est nu keeper de water tower
vient de suède
on a des partenaires notamment
des dessinateurs d'une bd qui seront là
pour montrer
ce qu'ils font au quotidien et
et honte à toi aussi
et après la fureur et le métal un peu de
douceur sur le plateau du kiosque avec
aurélia
nous sommes mercredi découvrons à
présent vos sorties ciné au micro d'
elodie moines ouais c'est pas mal enfin
y'a qu'un rôle pratiquement que c'est
l'histoire se répète si je trouve un peu
de longueur de change assez bien c'est
un bon film sur les sentiments mais j'ai
beaucoup pris mais ce film très très
émouvant très réaliste un univers qui
toise un petit peu voilà les gens qui ne
sont pas de ce milieu et voilà
franchement c'est un super super bon
film enfin j'ai trouvé ça on peut un peu
trop de surface je pense que ça aurait
pu être plus abouti que ça les
personnages intéressants mais scénario
passants peuvent passer ambitieux pour
moi une déception pour du kronenberger
bonne comédie parfois un petit peu
absurde mais dans l'ensemble plutôt
convenable je trouve qu'il est plus fort
que les derniers qu'on a vu
ça déménage à sec est de mise en scène
des effets spéciaux improbable va
c'était vachement bien j'ai beaucoup
apprécié ce film
je suis fan des marvel un soin sont en
général et celui ci a peut-être une
pointe d'originalité par rapport à ce
qu'on a pu le vendre qu'il ya beaucoup
d'action entre les deux époques les tout
est très bien retransmis et tout s'est
très très bien foutu il n'y a pas de pas
de cohérence
chaque semaine le ciel et marées mise à
l'honneur dans notre chronique
cinéphiles et c'est au tour de cyril
haddad projectionniste à l'espace
philippe noiret des clayes-sous-bois de
nous livrer son coup de coeur
cette semaine le coup de coeur de
l'espace philippe noiret et le film
barbecue à 50 ans antoine incarné par
lambert wilson est victime d'un
infarctus
antoine a l'air en forme
puisque les antoine et pourquoi fais tu
es foutu vient d'en réchapper la vie
varie désormais il va adopter un nouveau
régime mais en voulant changer sa vie il
va forcément changer celles de ses amis
du réalisateur eric lavaine tisse une
comédie qui se laisse savourer il
dépeint les amis qui est contrarié d'un
groupe de quadras et des quinquas
barbecue fait partager un vrai moment de
convivialité
ce film est un bon divertissement à
découvrir cette semaine à l'espace et
une oreille
allez je vous propose à présent d'autres
idées de sorties ces prochains jours
alors tout d'abord samedi 24 mai la
ferme de bel ébat consacre une journée
entière aux marionnettes cinq spectacles
où le public grandit au fil des heures
les solistes de lavilledieu donneront
leur dernier concert de la saison samedi
également que ce sera à 18 heures à
l'auditorium de trappes un programme
consacré à vienne et au romantisme et
influences hongroise voilà notre
émission est à présent terminé merci de
nous avoir suivi sur tv fiche vous
retrouve donc la semaine prochaine en
direct à 18h30 à mercredi